marjorie taylor green speaking of
speaking of white nationalists um
marjorie taylor greene
she was at it at her republican primary
debate
it is it is worth watching here let's
let's go to it here i forget the guy
that they're the opponent's name he's a
republican he really puts her in his in
i think his name is sean or seth yeah
something like that i i don't know he's
a republican and he's i mean he's likely
to be just as much of a sycophant to
trump as anyone else but here here is
the example of how we draw wedges
in between these republicans to win the
2022 midterm this this right here is the
is the map and the blueprint folks
watch what he does and democrats need to
keep doing this all over the place to
draw wedges between these candidates uh
to to tamp down and to suppress their
vote that's right folks
we're all here because we have concerns
about the seat
see you bought defense contractor stock
before railing against profitable wars
your words and actions are consistently
inconsistent no bill you've authored has
passed
before before we watch the this do you
think she says the words do not recall
i'm almost
i i almost think that's like a like a
recording that she has that she's like i
do not recall i didn't know she has an
easy button right right right right
she likes your mouth any move it's just
just like just pull the string on the
dummy
well i mean you know
you're what you're gonna see here is a
bunch of lawyer talk this person is is
obviously
and her attorneys obviously think that
she actually has some criminal liability
towards the insurrection to some degree
otherwise she wouldn't say some of the
stuff she's saying how she's saying it
but listen to what she says here and you
have no committee power to advocate for
this district
without resorting to rhetoric about
democrat boogeyman biden and the wolf
left answer this can you tell us one or
two specific objectives that affect our
wallets that you can actually pass and
explain how you plan to get it done
without being guaranteed a committee
assignment
well thank you very much
and
okay
safe to assume
she does not say i don't recall
i think she's gonna answer
but i wouldn't be surprised if she also
gives a non-answer well i mean this is
marjorie taylor green that we're right
she's gonna i mean here's the thing he
said don't mention like the woke left in
this i i have a feeling
throw it in there she's she may not say
woke left exactly but i i bet she throws
something in there that's like something
to the of the deep state or whatever the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that she tries to smear
all over there i guarantee she gives a
non-answer and tries to blame someone
else and she's she's totally she
you haven't seen this clip then you
haven't watched no no no no because i i
pulled my uh that my desk she says
you're welcome minus robin says you're
welcome today thank you for pointing
this clip out i actually went and pulled
it and posted it on our podcast uh
twitter account for everyone to see um
but gabe gabe haven't seen this yet so
let's listen and let's see what his
response is to uh to uh her foot greens
here um her answer to his question
committee assignment
well thank you for that question seth
and and i know you this is your first
time being a candidate as well so i
usually find out about stock trades when
i read them in the news just like you
have i signed an agreement with our
financial advisor that i don't know
anything about trades that are made she
doesn't recall gabe she doesn't recall
she didn't say
when they're written by leftist like
business insider there it is there it is
there's leftist like business business
insider you bunch of [ __ ] letters so
so that means wait hold on so that means
she gets if you recall what she just
said she said she does not hear about
them until they're in the right in the
trades right
and then she she signed an agreement
which doesn't really mean anything in
terms of with her financial advisor now
what she's saying is she doesn't hear
about them until they're in leftist uh
articles like business insider which
means she's getting her trade
information from leftist articles right
in publications right this answer is
[ __ ]
let's let's let's let's listen to the
rest of hoof it's um diatribe here just
like you're talking about now here's
what we have to do you have to
understand and remember democrats are in
control in washington right now she's
telling other people to remember right
right
the person who doesn't recall anything
is telling other people to remember all
right so she didn't say deep state she
didn't say woke love she said the
democrats are in control so she it
sounds like she's going to blame them
right well we're not getting anything
done right absolutely right well let's
let's hear what she says republicans
aren't getting anything done even the
republicans on committees aren't getting
anything done and it's so so now so now
it's anyone who's not on a committee are
the actual ones who are getting things
done right do you notice that democrats
who are on committees are in control of
committees they're not getting anything
the republicans who are actually on
committee escape they're not getting
anything done
they're definitely it's the only the
only people like me who are not on
committees right who can't introduce
legislation into committees to make sure
they get to the house floor i can only
go to the house floor and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] in front of a microphone
and be a racist white nationalist piece
of [ __ ]
a manga king
mass shooter enabler and then that
that's the only that's the only voice
that i have what a bonehead let's let's
listen to more of the bone injury if
they were you wouldn't see the radical
destruction of america going on right
now our wide open borders we are having
inflation out of control and we are no
longer energy independent as americans
so what i look forward to doing is we
were never energy independent
let me ask you gabe are you energy
independent do you have your own energy
like i mean your independent is your
energy uh
like me per my body yeah well yeah she
said americans aren't energy independent
well i mean my body america actually
my body needs to
need sustenance you know so i have to
have to actually eat stuff
so i'm not actually i'm not independent
it's not like my body is a is a is a you
know
infinitely going uh
battery you know i'm not like i'm not
like the matrix where you plug me in and
boom boom i still have to have nutrients
to feed oh okay to create the fuel you
know and and energy like she wants
americans
she wants americans to be energy
independent not america right
hands when have we ever been energy
independent don't know this is all
fossil fuels
we have obviously drilling in in the
united states but we
certainly import our stuff we have never
been energy independent complete energy
independence would be we don't rely on
anyone else we've got sustainable energy
and actual solutions and things that
don't require us to say oh [ __ ] when all
this [ __ ] thing burns up you mean a
finite resource so there's a good theory
out there it's called the the peanuts in
the room theory have you ever heard this
theory before so what is it a gallery
well well not exactly but it's a room
full if i gave you a room full that was
packed full like a bedroom-sized room
full of peanuts yeah and i told you gabe
that you could have all these peanuts
and you can eat as many as you want but
you can't take the shells out of the
room you can't take the shells out of
the room you cannot you can't remove the
shells you can de-shell the peanuts and
you can eat the peanuts but you can't
take the shells out of the room so how
how long do you think it'll take until
you're just tired of looking for peanuts
still in the shell how long do you think
it would take oh pretty quickly right
now here's the reason why we don't want
to be oil independent in this country
because that's really what she's saying
she's not saying energy independent as
we only produce our energy here she's
saying we only want to buy oil that is
american oil
which is [ __ ] ridiculous because we
give federal contracts to all kinds of
foreign companies to actually come here
and drill for the oil
bp is not an american company okay
british british petroleum
wait wait wait the same british that
america tried to you know
leave right
we had a war with a tyrannical
government you know the reason why we
have to have our second amendment rights
second amendment to fend off british
petroleum now the reason
the reason why we don't want to be
energy independent is exactly the peanut
shell theory because if we actually use
up the entirety of our oil reserves that
we as america and our nation owns
eventually it'll be really hard to look
for it and we won't look for it anymore
it won't be cost effective to look for
it so what we do is we actually buy a
buy crude oil do you know what crude oil
is they pump it out of the ground
and they they ship it over here from
other countries and we buy it from them
so we don't have to actually use our
finite resource which makes
us energy independent by us not drilling
all of our oil gabe it makes us oil
independent when we're not it seems like
it's like oil responsible right well
right because you don't wanna if you had
a backup supply let's say that you had
like um
um
like a bunch of stuff in case something
goes wrong right like uh you're like hey
we've got this on a reserve almost like
an oil reserve in case
[ __ ] hits the fan and we've got a we've
got to pull from the reserve to kind of
replenish our supply and maybe there's
an overseas kind of crisis that might be
creating a shortage and we need to rely
on that if we use all our oil like
you're saying then we wouldn't have that
reserve which means and then we're
paying out of the ass for someone else
to give us that's potentially shitty oil
that's got a bunch of sand and dirt in
it right is everything so what you're
what yeah what i'm saying is if we if we
take all of our
finite resources whether they be oil or
anything else and we only use them here
and we and we mine them we drill them we
pump them and we suck them out and we
use them
eventually we won't look for them
because it won't be cost effective
because there'll be too many peanut
shells in the room to look for peanuts
number one number two we won't have
peanuts anymore we will give up on the
room so we won't be energy independent
pull your
heads out of your asses it's almost like
hey
super chat
thank you it's almost like
we need
renewable
no energy oh gabe gabe that is that is
that radical liberal socialist i'm just
saying if there's a shortage there's a
finite amount of resources what you're
saying is energy get resources that
aren't finite like what like what could
that possibly be i don't know like uh
hydro power
uh or
or or
air right like wind solar you and your
commie wind turbines i'm just saying
like if we look at the elements of the
earth right earth wind
fire right land you know uh right are
you gonna start singing earth when the
environment yeah you know it i you know
then sing the song in september you know
anyway
you have these elements and you know if
you've got hydro related energy
resources you've got wind related energy
resources you've got solar you know
these seem to be like resources that we
have enough of that we can reuse right
we don't just use it and lose it
we are able actually to
to renew these resources on an ongoing
basis you know it's almost like they're
infinite they're not entirely infinite
for some but they seem like they're
infinite for the most part right
i i i believe i believe wind will keep
blowing rain will keep falling and the
sun will keep shining as long as long as
we don't drill the hell out of the earth
and cause it not to be that way um we
got another super chat in here donated
in the name of baron von schneider's
name thanks for driving donations i'm a
strong woman god supports
not threatening not threatened by and
guess what i carry kevin says thank you
for the super debt
so let's let's listen sorry to get us a
sidetracked on um what
what energy independence means let's
listen to what the bone is i love this
face though by the way i almost don't
want to play this now that their faces
pause this way you need to take a screen
campus and use it on one of our famous
thumbnails let's
let's continue here back the house i'll
have great committee assignments kevin
mccarthy leadership of rms to them
to me and we look forward to holding
democrats accountable for all the
corruption and horrible things they've
done in our country thank you okay let's
give a seth a 30 cents a response so do
you hear that kevin mccarthy has
promised folks if you need any other
ambition out there and this is this is
what i was talking about when i said
this is the wedges that they are
designing to draw right
if you have any other
wedge that you need to draw it is the
kevin mccarthy
kevin mccarthy has promised marjorie
taylor green which means that he's
promised madison caught thorn
he might even promise them chair
chairwoman chips who knows who knows
they may be in charge of these
committees are you going to go vote are
you going to let marjorie taylor green
be the chairwoman of the economic
committee of the foreign relations
committee are you going to do that huh
huh
well
go vote let's see what's it's his name
seth i think he said yeah let's see what
seth here his rebuttal
that's too big an if
voting for mrs green is a gamble that
she's not guaranteed to committee power
she's not even accountable for her own
tweets or her staffs
we're still not clear who's acting on
the district's behalf
now that there's another wedge to draw
between these republicans have you
noticed this game that they have taken a
lot of their official accounts
like uh and they they've they've kind of
branded them as press
release account
right they've started to do that and
it's because of her and it's because of
paul gosar and some of these others
because they want to blame their staff
right right they want to blame their
staff on any any tweets that they might
throw out there on their official
congressional accounts and that's what
he's talking about here because this
idea that she doesn't have a twitter
account because uh
it's kind of ridiculous she does have
one she does tweet she tweets all the
time from this twitter account let's
listen to what seth says so how can
anyone expect her to bring
accountability to washington
her only leadership trait right now is
rallying people against an enemy
and little to none of what she just said
encourages business in our district
or fights out of control inflation
so there you have it again
what did i say a non-answer she went in
he was like yo give me the actual
policies that you will pass if you are
re-elected right i want to know what
you're doing i want the people
of your district to know exactly
what you are trying to do to help them
right there are issues at hand what do
you actually like what solutions are you
offering and she goes in and says well
you know it's run by the democrats the
house and the the hill and uh we don't
really have as much uh control as we did
once but once i'm reelected uh kevin
mccarthy told me he's promised me so
just go to take me take my word for it
not worth [ __ ] two cents
uh take my word for it that when i get
back into that seat for this district
kevin mccarthy is going to put me on a
that's right on a on a committee he's
going to be on many companies he's going
to be on so many committees he's going
to be the best committees ever right